a tentative restart at Hong Kong
International but it's anything but
business as usual the day began with few
signs at the mass protests that brought
the airport to his standstill on Monday
but it may prove a brief respite
hundreds of flights remained canceled
officials warned many others would need
to be rerouted after the shutdown for
some weary travelers a mix of
frustration and sympathy it hasn't been
funny I don't think I will ever fly Hong
Kong again there yeah
things that are going there going on and
I'm with like Hong Kong people and yeah
hopefully - yeah things get there and
everyone gets yeah safely home Hong
Kong's
Airport one of the world's busiest is
now ground zero for protesters and their
challenge to Beijing thousands staged to
sit in here on Monday outraged over what
they see as the erosion of their
democratic freedoms by China
inconvenience or selfishness cost to
other people but we cannot avoid this
it's somehow I've no I'm not more noble
because we fight for a final goal that
is our freedom
protesters anger fueled as well buy
fresh scenes of police violence on
Sunday they fired tear gas at close
range at demonstrators inside a subway
station and charged many with batons
these violent scenes are now a growing
part of the biggest crisis Hong Kong has
seen in decades but the territory's
chief executive defended the police and
gave no sign of concessions at a tense
press conference
the chief executives responsibility is
to ensure that Hong Kong remains a safe
and orderly and law-abiding City that is
my utmost responsibility as protesters
show no signs of backing down the
territory's rulers have ramped up their
rhetoric denouncing some violent
demonstrations as terrorism for the
first time that many fear could be a
prelude to a harsh crackdown under
anti-terror laws and joining me from
Hong Kong International Airport is our
very own Phoebe Kong
Phoebe even though the airport is open
again many flights are still canceled to
understand does that mean that we can
expect further unrest at the airport
while they're having another assembly
for the fifth trick stay here at the
Hong Kong International Airport and
right nearby where I'm standing right
here boo testers they are now gathering
at the arrivals for the so far as you
can see behind me there are tourists and
passengers walking through at the
departure for they're like going to
depart Hong Kong and somewhere there is
no chaos or disruption caused to the
operation of the airport although over
200 flights has been cancelled I
canceled by the Hong kong-based carrier
can they receive it but other flights
are operated by other allies around the
world when resumed normally and
protesters they're now gathering their
chants tokens and somehow this walk
around in the terminal and they try to
spread the message to the tourists
arriving Hong Kong from different from
different part of the world they try to
distribute handbills to them and so far
we makes peaceful the enemy is not that
chance at this airport the protester
obviously continuing and I understand
that they're actually spreading to other
locations what can you tell us about
that
yes apart from the airport there are
rallies are organized and held and over
till hospitals across Hong Kong today
and hundreds of medical staff including
doctors and nurses they protest against
the alleged brutality of the Hong Kong
police force say so what they wear black
masks and they wear black ribbons on
their uniforms and the protest as where
they work which is their hospitals and
they are trying to urge the government
especially the police force not to
further how having the citizens are like
in the future and that is the major
demands and we can see there are
professionals
medical professionals coming out
standing out to voice their concerns to
us the excessive force used by the Hong
Kong police force Hong Kong authorities
in the Chinese government are using
increasingly sharp language to condemn
the protests the word terrorism has been
used what do these latest statements
tell us about the authorities strategy
for resolving the situation
well it has been mentioned in the report
earlier that
carolien have met depressed earlier
today and she and she tried to reiterate
it the consummation to was the violence
of the so-called rioters and the
government's they are not backing now
anyway they're not making any compromise
to any of the demands of the protesters
but instead they are using a harsh
language to condemn the protesters
action such as Carolina saying that the
protesters have simply no stake every
society and the Beijing Authority they
even described the protesters as
terrorists so we can see that this is
not something this is not a good time to
cool down the situation but people
further trigger felons
are very likely in the future PV thank
you very much bringing us up to date our
correspondent there in Hong Kong Phoebe
calm